one single scientist created three
inventions that accidentally caused the
deaths of millions of people
including himself
not only that they decreased the average
intelligence of people all around the
world increased crime rates and caused
two completely separate environmental
disasters that we are still dealing with
today
part of this video is sponsored by ren
more about them at the end of the show
in 1944 as a young chemist who had just
finished his masters claire patterson
went to work on the manhattan project
building the first nuclear weapons his
job was to concentrate
uranium-235 the fissile fuel for bombs
from the much more common uranium-238
and this required huge machines mass
spectrometers which separated the two
types of uranium by their slight
difference in mass
after the war patterson went back to
grad school to get his phd
he picked a research project that would
take advantage of his experience with
mass spectrometers
measuring the age of the earth
radioactive rocks are effectively clocks
uranium-238 for example decays into
thorium and then protactinium and then
12 more decays until it ends up as lead
206 which is stable
the rate of this decay is consistent and
can be measured it takes four and a half
billion years for half of a sample of
u-238 to decay into lead 206.
patterson's phd project was to determine
the age of the earth by measuring the
ratio of uranium to lead in primordial
rocks
but to calibrate his instrument first he
used zircon crystals whose ages were
known
zircon is ideal for this purpose because
when it forms it contains trace amounts
of uranium but absolutely no lead
so any lead that you later find inside a
zircon you know must be the product of a
uranium decay
now patterson was tasked with measuring
the lead content and another student
george tilton measured uranium
tilton's uranium measurements were fine
they matched predictions
but patterson's lead measurements were
all over the place and they were many
many times higher than they expected we
take georgia's uranium and my lead
not right patterson
there was lead there that didn't belong
there
so where was all this extra lead coming
from
that mystery would take over the rest of
claire patterson's life and bring him to
the literal ends of the earth
in 1908 a woman was driving across the
belle isle bridge in detroit when her
car stalled
a passing motorist stopped to help in
those days cars needed to be hand
cranked to start
he knelt down and turned the crank and
the engine roared to life a little too
suddenly
the man couldn't get out of the way the
crank handle hit him in the face and
broke his jaw
he died as a result of his injuries
his name was byron carter and he was the
founder of his own car company so he was
well connected in the detroit auto scene
he counted among his close friends the
founder of cadillac henry leland
leland was so distraught over his
friend's death that he resolved to
eliminate hand cranks from his vehicles
leland hired charles kettering to create
a self-starting car and by 1911 he had a
working prototype
hand cranking was difficult and
dangerous
and best left to men
but a car that started itself changed
everything
the world's first crankless car was the
cadillac model 30. it was much more
powerful than cars before it it had a
top speed of 45 miles per hour and 40
horsepower double the ford model t
the model 30 was a huge success for
cadillac doubling the company's annual
sales
but it had a problem it was definitely
loud
in internal combustion engines a piston
compresses the fuel air mixture which is
then ignited by a spark from the spark
plug the expanding hot gases push the
piston back down
the problem with the model 30 engine was
it compressed the fuel air mixture more
than previous models so much in fact
that often the fuel would spontaneously
combust before the spark from the spark
plug so rather than orderly perfectly
timed explosions you'd get multiple
haphazard combustions leading to
turbulent pressure waves inside the
cylinder the resulting sound led the
problem to become known as engine
knocking
knocking wasn't just hard on the ears it
hurt the engine's performance it reduced
power output and lowered fuel efficiency
the vibrations also damaged the piston
and walls of the cylinder shortening the
life of the engine
the good news was that engine knocking
could be corrected by changing the fuel
different fuels can withstand different
levels of compression before detonating
n-heptane for example will spontaneously
combust under only a little compression
iso-octane on the other hand can
withstand a much higher compression
ratio before it auto-ignites so it's
much less likely to cause knocking to
quantify how much compression a fuel can
withstand scientists came up with the
octane rating system they arbitrarily
set iso-octane to have a rating of 100
and n-heptane a rating of zero
now real fuels aren't made up of only
these two ingredients they're a mix of
lots of different hydrocarbons but the
octane rating tells you what mixture of
octane and heptane gives equivalent
performance for example 98 octane fuel
can withstand the same compression as a
mixture of 98 octane and 2 percent
heptane now i'm going to take a little
bit of 98 octane fuel and put it in this
piston
and when i compress it
nothing happens which is exactly what
you'd expect this fuel can withstand a
lot of compression diesel has an octane
rating of 20 so it acts like a mixture
of 20 percent iso octane and 80 and
heptane if i put a little bit of diesel
in there
let's see what happens with the same
compression ratio
there you go you get a little explosion
in there that's because this is a low
octane fuel i mean that's what diesel's
meant to do you compress it and it
ignites but you don't want this sort of
fuel in an engine with spark plugs
the reason fancy cars demand high octane
fuel is to prevent knocking in their
high compression high performance
engines
kettering wanted to find an additive
which would increase the octane rating
of ordinary fuel and eliminate knocking
in high compression engines so he hired
27 year old engineer thomas midgley jr
midgley experimented with all sorts of
compounds from melted butter and camphor
to ethyl acetate and aluminum chloride
he later wrote most of them had no more
effect than spitting in the great lakes
ethanol was an interesting exception it
did stop the knocking but you needed a
lot of it about 10 percent of the fuel
mixture for it to be effective that much
ethanol would be expensive and hard to
turn a profit on and midgley was really
after an additive that was cheap easy to
produce and effective even at low
concentrations
so he kept trying
then he hit on tellurium it worked
wonderfully as an anti-knock agent but
it had a terrible smell
you couldn't get rid of it by changing
clothes or bathing his wife was so
offended by the stench that he had to
sleep in the basement for seven months
midgley wrote i don't think that
although this doubled the fuel economy
humanity would suffer this smell
on december 3rd 1921 after five years of
working on the problem midgley found
what he thought was the perfect solution
tetraethyl lead that's a lead atom right
there in the center this additive was
exactly what he was looking for it
stopped the knocking it didn't smell it
was cheap to produce and readily
available best of all you only needed
one part in a thousand for it to be
effective
in a call to kettering midgley said can
you imagine how much money we're gonna
make with this we're gonna make 200
million dollars maybe even more
that is over three billion in today's
dollars
now for his discovery the american
chemical society gave him the
prestigious nichols award and they asked
him to do a series of public talks but
midgley declined
he and kettering patented the process
for making tetraethyl lead and they
called their new additive ethel perhaps
so it might be confused with another
common additive ethyl alcohol they made
no mention of lead
then they teamed up with three of
america's largest corporations general
motors dupont and standard oil of new
jersey to form the ethel corporation
marketing was brilliant
no man can look at the amazing record of
accomplishment here in this research
division without confidence that these
men are going ahead with an eye to the
future
looking for new facts and principles
which will make things better and make
life easier for all of us
at the 1923 indianapolis 500 the top
three finishers all used ethel and the
demand for leaded gasoline took off
to keep up ethel corporation had to
build a new chemical plant in new jersey
but the project began terribly within
two months of operating dozens of
workers fell ill with lead poisoning
five of them died
to address the public outcry midgley
held a press conference and there he
poured tetraethyl lead onto his hands
and he inhaled it for a full minute he
claimed he could do this daily without
harm
but midgley knew the dangers
the reason he had turned down the public
talks was because he spent much of 1923
in florida where he himself was
recovering from lead poisoning
he didn't go anywhere near his company's
product if he could help it
lead is dangerous even in small doses it
mimics calcium in our bodies so there's
no efficient way to get rid of it and
like calcium lead can be stored in bones
for years meaning it can continue to
poison the body long after the initial
exposure the organ most sensitive to
lead is the brain
lead breaks down the myelin sheath
around axons and prevents the release of
neurotransmitters that's why common
symptoms of lead poisoning are headaches
memory loss and tingling in the hands
and feet and children are particularly
susceptible lead exposure can cause
permanent learning disorders and
behavioral problems and the dangers of
lead have been known for hundreds of
years already in 1786 benjamin franklin
remarked that lead had been used for far
too long considering its known toxicity
you will observe with concern how long a
useful truth may be known and exist
before it is generally received and
practiced on
he would have been aghast to learn that
nearly 150 years later scientists plan
to add lead to fuel
doctors and public health officials from
mit harvard yale and the u.s health
service wrote to midgley and warned them
against producing tetraethyl lead they
called lead a creeping and malicious
poison and a serious menace to public
health
their concerns were dismissed
this model shows how just the right
amount of fluid containing tetraethyl
lead and dye is added to the gasoline no
one doubted that a lot of lead was bad
for you but how much harm could a little
lead do
by the 1950s millions of motorists
globally were burning lead in their cars
and releasing it into the air
some of that lead ended up on claire
patterson's zircon samples preventing
him from determining their age
in 1952 he moved to caltech where he
built a new lab from scratch suspicious
of environmental contamination he tore
the electrical cables out of the walls
to remove the lead solder
he cleaned the floors and benches daily
with ammonia and made sure that air was
always being blown out of the lab
to go inside you had to wear a plastic
bunny suit patterson basically invented
the clean room
inside that room he turned his attention
to the oldest rocks in the solar system
meteorites
all the original rocks on earth had long
since been destroyed by tectonic
activity
but meteorites come from asteroids which
formed around the same time as earth
they have just been drifting through
space until they entered the earth's
atmosphere so the best way to measure
the age of the earth was to measure the
age of meteorites
patterson
measured five meteorites each with three
different radiometric dating techniques
and he found they were all
4.55
billion years old that number is within
0.15 percent of the currently accepted
value for the age of the earth you know
before patterson's experiment people
thought the earth was a billion years
younger
so patterson had done it he measured the
age of the earth but he wasn't done
getting rid of lead contaminants
public concern about lead exposure had
continued to grow but president of
standard oil frank howard pushed back
saying we do not feel justified in
giving up what has come to the industry
like a gift from heaven on the
possibility that a hazard may be
involved in it
scientists funded by the ethel
corporation claimed that lead was a
natural part of our environment and
therefore not harmful to people
but patterson wondered
just how natural is the lead in our
environment
and he had just the skills to find out
began by measuring lead in the oceans if
it were natural he expected the
concentration of lead to be the same
regardless of depth but if lead
pollution had increased recently it
would be more concentrated near the
surface
he took samples in the pacific and
atlantic oceans down to a depth of four
kilometers and sure enough lead
concentrations were nearly 10 times
higher near the surface
lead pollution was clearly recent
but when exactly had it occurred
to find out patterson had to go to
greenland and antarctica
ice cores record the level of lead in
the air going back thousands of years
the levels of lead in the atmosphere
have been elevated for the last 4 500
years all of it is due to human activity
mainly smelting oars to make metal
you can see the rise and fall of the
greek and roman empires
the dip caused by the black death in the
1300s and of course the spike in the
20th century due to industrialization
and tetraethyl lead
so what did this do to people
well patterson looked at the lead levels
in the teeth and bones of recently
deceased americans and for comparison he
measured the lead in bones and teeth of
peruvian and egyptian mummies
since they lived over 1600 years ago
they would have been exposed to much
less lead in their lifetimes
he expected to find modern americans had
about a hundred times as much lead in
their bones but results showed it was
closer to a factor of a thousand
twentieth century americans had a
thousand times more lead in their bones
than their ancestors
studies of baby teeth revealed that even
lead exposure well below the level
considered safe resulted in delayed
learning decreased iq and increased
behavioral problems and there is a
broad consensus on the part of everybody
except the lead industry in this
spokesman that lead is extremely toxic
at extremely low doses
a follow-up study showed that those with
higher levels of lead in their baby
teeth were many times more likely to
fail out of high school as a result of
studies like these the cdc's guidelines
for the acceptable level of lead in
children's blood dropped from 60
micrograms per deciliter down to 3.5
and as far as we know today there is no
safe level of lead
globally lead is believed to be
responsible for nearly two-thirds of all
unexplained intellectual disability
according to a study published in 2022
more than half of the current u.s
population that's 170 million people
were exposed to high levels of lead in
early childhood those born between 1951
and 1980 are disproportionately affected
the authors estimate that in aggregate
lead caused a loss of more than 800
million iq points
the world is less intelligent today
because of leaded gasoline
but there are even more troubling
correlations
the u.s saw a steady rise in crime from
the 1970s to the 1990s
then it abruptly declined
this graph looks eerily similar to a
plot of preschool blood lead levels just
offset by 20 years
the obvious question is did kids who
were exposed to higher levels of lead
grow up to commit more crimes than they
otherwise would have
you might think this is just a spurious
correlation but the same pattern appears
in many countries including britain
canada and australia and we know there
is a causal connection between lead
exposure and anti-social or violent
behavior a study of 340 teenagers found
that those who were arrested were four
times as likely to have elevated lead in
their bones than similar demographic
controls who didn't have run-ins with
the law
now this doesn't mean that lead is
responsible for all of the increase in
crime but it's very likely responsible
for some of it
now it's tough to estimate the precise
death toll of lead one of its
lesser-known effects is a hardening of
the arteries leading to increased
cardiovascular disease a study from 2018
found lead was likely responsible for
250 000 heart disease deaths per year in
the u.s assuming a constant rate over
the past century that amounts to 25
million deaths in the u.s alone globally
the figure may approach a hundred
million
most of those deaths are due to
midgley's decision to put lead in
gasoline a substance he knew firsthand
was toxic but he did it anyway to
maximize profits
and the problem is not over current
estimates of deaths caused by lead range
from 500 to 900 000 per year the 2020
unicef report warns that one in three
children globally that's over 800
million children have blood lead levels
at or above 5 micrograms per deciliter
a lot of this lead now comes from
batteries and industrial processes but
some is still due to midgley's invention
after midgley's success with ethel he
was put in charge of another engineering
project gm wasn't just making cars but
also household appliances and fridges
had a problem the two most common gases
used as refrigerants were methyl formate
and sulfur dioxide one is highly toxic
the other is flammable
midgley was tasked with creating a safer
alternative and in 1928 he developed a
non-toxic and non-flammable refrigerant
dichlorodifluoromethane
gm called this new product freon and to
demonstrate freon safety during the
unveiling at the american chemical
society midgley inhaled a lungful of
this gas and blew out a candle
in the following decades cfcs like freon
became very popular and were used as
solvents and aerosols
the problem is cfcs are light and stable
when released into the atmosphere they
climb up into the stratosphere where
they can remain for 50 to 100 years but
if a cfc molecule is hit by an
ultraviolet photon of just the right
energy it breaks apart releasing a
chlorine atom this chlorine atom can
then react with ozone
breaking it apart into chlorine monoxide
and oxygen gas
the result was another environmental
disaster the hole in the ozone layer
with less ozone more uv light penetrates
the atmosphere increasing the rates of
skin cancer and cataracts plus cfcs are
potent greenhouse gases per kilogram
they produce 10 000 times more warming
than co2 the historian john mcneil wrote
that midgley had more impact on the
atmosphere than any other single
organism in earth's history
an agreement to phased out cfcs the
montreal protocol went into effect in
1989 and the ozone layer is now showing
signs of recovery although it will take
many more decades to fully recover
in 1940 at the age of 51 midgley
contracted polio and became physically
disabled so to help him get up he
devised a mechanical bed controlled by a
series of ropes and pulleys
on november 2nd 1944 while using the
contraption he became tangled in the
ropes and died of strangulation
thanks to the work of claire patterson
it became clear that the lead in our
environment is not natural
burning lead and combustion engines
spread the toxic element across the
planet into the air oceans the snow at
the south pole and even our bones
japan was the first to ban leaded fuel
in cars in 1986 but other countries soon
followed suit algeria was the last to do
so in 2021
the un calculates that the elimination
of lead from gas saves over a million
lives per year and 2.45 trillion dollars
but leaded gas is still used by the way
in piston driven airplane engines that's
now the largest source of lead emissions
into the air in the u.s
you will observe with concern how long a
useful truth may be known and exist
before it is generally received and
practiced
on when i first learned about thomas
midgley and claire patterson i was
amazed by how much harm or how much good
a single person could do to the
environment which brings me to the
sponsor of this video ren an
organization that's taking action on
climate change
i think it's important that we tackle
the climate crisis both by lobbying for
systemic change and by making more
environmentally friendly choices
ourselves on ren's website you can
calculate how much carbon you emit and
which activities have the greatest
impact and if you like you can offset
your emissions through a monthly
subscription the funds raised go to
support a variety of projects that
reduce greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere one project i particularly
like involves collecting up flammable
dead wood from california forests this
helps prevent wildfires plus the
collected wood is converted into biochar
a material that locks up the carbon
inside for thousands of years once you
sign up to offset your carbon footprint
you'll receive monthly updates from the
projects you support it's completely
transparent with photos and details of
every tree planted every acre reforested
every ton of carbon offset and for the
first 100 people who sign up using the
link in the description i will
personally pay for the first month of
your subscription so i want to thank ren
for supporting veritasium and i want to
thank you for watching